you would think there's a science
fiction but it's not hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with Reason TV and today we're
talking with Peter Y Marsh Towson of
shapeways a 3d printing company
elaborate on what you do you create
things out of 3d printing let's say I
have an idea for a product
how does shape ways help me make that
same place is an online community and
marketplace for people to bring their
ideas to life so how do we help well it
depends on who you are if you are
looking for the perfect gift or if
you're looking for a great product you
can visit our website and there is like
hundreds of thousands of products that
people have created thousands of those
you can customize and then if you like
it then you can buy it and we make it
just in time
we make it on the man for you I mean
it's kind of like zazzle or something
with t-shirts or shoes I mean they're
you among other things you have a
marketplace of things that have already
been done that people can pick and say
ok do it like this and then you'll send
it to them yes and then we make it and
this is where the magic starts we make
it using 3d printers right and that is
enables us to make custom products
almost as efficiently as we would make
Maspero so we talked a little bit about
that like what kinds of products can you
make could you make an air conditioner
if I design that and send it to me or
are you doing more kind of smaller scale
trinkets object art things like that
well currently most 3d printing
technology the ones that we offer use
only one material so an air conditioner
is not right in the realm of
possibilities but you can make things
like jewelry you can make all kinds of
things that consist of one material
right who are some of your clients and
what are what are some of the things
beyond what you just mentioned that
you're making for that we are both for
people who are looking for something
cool for themselves but also if you are
a maker and you can use 3d software
mm-hmm you can create anything in that
software upload it to us and we'll make
it for you right besides that if you
want to use it what you've created and
you think it serves a purpose or it
solves a problem you can start selling
that on Shapeways to it you said that
something like an air conditioner is
kind of beyond the capability of the
technology
now and so I mean I know that 3d
printing is a kind of lazy analogy of
what you're doing because it's really
manufacturing but are we and kind of
we're in kind of the dot-matrix era of
3d printing and how long will it be
before you can do something like an
air-conditioner or an automobile engine
or something you know that Sony printing
has been around for quite a while but it
has been used in a very limited scope 3d
printing initially was used for
prototyping of products that time are
later on mass-produced that happened for
since the late 1980s up until like MIT
maybe you know 2005 six or so and then
slowly but surely you know it's been
used for final products right now as I
mentioned it's only in final products in
those materials but what is happening
because it's adaptation because more and
more people learn about this and more
and more people start to use it the guys
who are making the printers themselves
those industrial type machines they
start to listen to the demands and they
are improving their machines hopefully
in an increasingly fast rate so the
questions that come in translate into
requirements and the machines get better
now one of the things like going back to
your question about the air conditioner
and one of the things that I'm really
excited about is that multi-material is
already possible and one of the things
we're definitely looking at is how can
you make products composed of multiple
materials and then this is the next step
if one of those materials is a
semiconductor you can start making
electrical appliances now you would
think this is science fiction but it's
not how do you think 3d printing will
will change the future of shopping well
first of all a nice quote I heard today
from from someone is that you know if
you're really exposed to the power that
this gives you and that you know
platform at shake which gives you you
get bored with the normal mass-produced
goods I like that and it's true because
now all of a sudden you can be involved
you can put your name on something you
can change the shape of something you
can change the material used and it
empowers our users you know the end user
benefits because the amount of choice in
what you can get will increase let me
flip that economy of scale so the the
first object is not you know it used in
traditional manufacturing the first
object might be a million dollars
and the second one is only $100 but if
the same unit cost for production is the
same all the way down does that mean
that there's no economy of scale here if
your thousandth cop costs the same as
the first cut to make well there is
economy of scale but it doesn't matter
what you're making and so it's more the
amount of stuff you're making mm-hmm
that makes it possible for for companies
like Shapeways to to set up smart
processes to drive down costs you know
if you have ten machines and a few
people running them that's obviously
more economical than one machine with
one guy run what and then if you
automate certain things around those
processes you get better cost
efficiencies as well
what does 3d printing mean for companies
say like Walmart which is the 800-pound
gorilla in retail and which is based on
really tightly understanding its supply
chain and doing things in a very
efficient way what what happens now a 3d
printer I think that 3d printing can
offer people different alternatives and
as always when things are told to be
different if there are you know
addressing the right needs then this
will be you know something that is of
interest to Walmart to look at obviously
how do you address that I don't know
that's up to them to decide but I think
what we see is that we empower the end
user much more than just by going to a
store and pick something that is
available on a shell throw we enable
people to be involved in the products
and I think they like what's the what's
the product do you have a kind of holy
grail product that you you know that
you'll know ok I finally reached the
endpoint when I when I produce this
thing I don't think there is an endpoint
I mean it's about like music songs keep
coming out I mean we have written so
many songs you know so many songs have
been written and still great new songs
come out the same will happen to product
and the same will happen to technology
it will get better and better actually I
think what we want to do as Shapeways is
not be about 3d printing but be about
empowering people to get products they
want well we'll end it there I want to
thank Peter why Mars Heusen why more
housing excuse me of Shapeways 3d
printing firm based in New York for
reason TV I'm Nicholas